Mein Name ist Michael Monstein.
Ich bin Vater von zwei Kindern.
Roter oder schwarzer Pfeffer?
Ich habe meine Diagnose
aus dem heiteren Himmel gekriegt.
Zwei Wochen später sah mein Leben
anders aus, und seither ist es so.
Er hat einen aggressiven Krebs.
Zwei Chemotherapien haben versagt.
Unbehandelt wäre es eine Sache
von zwei, maximal drei Monaten,
bis ich sterben würde.
Das ist ...
Ja, es ist wirklich ernst.
Seine letzte Hoffnung: eine
Gentherapie mit Krebskillerzellen.
Z.B. Kymriah von Novartis.
Kostenpunkt: 370'000 Fr.
Und Kymriah ist erst der Anfang.
(Frau) A new drug, LUXTURNA,
was injected into his eye.
850'000 $.
ZOLGENSMA - it's now
the most expensive drug on earth,
with a price tag of 2,1 Mio. $.
Was ist eine Gesellschaft
zu tragen bereit?
Wann lässt man einen
"billiger" sterben?
Wie kommt es zu diesen Preisen?
Die Pharma testet
den Markt selbstverständlich.
Was gibt der Markt her?
Wo ist die Limite des Markts?
Werden die Krankenkassen
die Rekordpreise bezahlen?
Das ist viel Geld, 370'000 Fr. -
zu viel für uns.
Was kann man denn da tun?
Es ist einfach schwierig.
Man kann nicht ganz absehen,
wie es weitergehen soll.
* Drängende, elektronische Klänge *
(Bub) Der Krebs kriegt jetzt
wirklich einen verpasst.
(Frau) Das hoffen wir.
Der kriegt eins auf den Deckel.
Das wäre schon gut, dann könnte ich
wieder mit euch in die Badi.
Es ist verrückt,
dass man ...
... einerseits in zwei Monaten
tot sein könnte
und andererseits in zwei Jahren
richtig geheilt sein könnte.
Michael Monstein hat eine seltene und
aggressive Form von Lymphdrüsenkrebs.
Auch sein schiefer Mund
rührt von der Krankheit.
(Frau) Das ist gut.
Seine letzte Hoffnung heisst Kymriah.
Eine völlig neue Therapie,
zugelassen seit letztem Herbst.
Dem Patienten werden
eigene Immunzellen entnommen.
Diese werden in die USA geschickt,
in ein Novartis-Labor.
Dort werden die Zellen
gentechnisch verändert
und zu Krebskillerzellen
umprogrammiert.
Die Killerzellen
werden vermehrt, eingefroren
und in die Schweiz zurückgeschickt.
Der Patient bekommt die Killerzellen
mit einer einmaligen Infusion.
Für die Infusion setzt Novartis
den Preis auf 370'000 Fr.
Ob die Krankenkassen Kymriah
vergüten, ist zunächst unklar.
Sie haben sich zusammengeschlossen,
um gemeinsam
einen Rabatt zu verhandeln.
Mein Name ist Martina Weiss.
Ich bin bei der Helsana
verantwortlich
für Vertragsverhandlungen
mit der Pharmaindustrie.
Wir verhandeln gerade über die
Vergütung von Kymriah mit Novartis.
370'000 Fr. seien zu viel,
man wisse nicht,
wie Kymriah langfristig wirke,
ob der Krebs
nicht wieder zurückkehre.
Uns ist nicht klar, wie
ein solcher Preis zustande kommt.
Wir haben
noch keine Auflistung erhalten,
wieso der Preis so hoch sein muss.
Macht die Pharma das normalerweise?
Eine ganz genaue Formel, wie der
Preis zustande kommt, gibt es nicht.
Oder die habe ich
zumindest nicht gesehen.
Man versucht, mit möglichst hohen
Preisvorstellungen reinzugehen.
Denn es ist doch Verhandlungssache.
Mit einem ersten Preis
schafft man einen Präzedenzfall.
Man läuft in ein Problem.
Die Lösung? Ich kenne sie nicht.
Diskutiert wird, ob die Krankenkassen
nur im Erfolgsfall zahlen sollen.
Was aber heisst bei Krebs "Erfolg"?
Eine Lösung liegt in weiter Ferne.
Vorläufig
entscheidet jede Kasse für sich.
Michael Monsteins Billigkasse Atupri
weigert sich,
Kymriah zu bezahlen.
Der Nutzen sei zu wenig klar,
heisst es.
Ich war richtig wütend, das ist
ein Zeugnis absoluter Inkompetenz.
Im Moment
ist es wie im Wilden Westen.
Wer es sich leisten kann, hat
Chancen, eine Therapie zu erhalten.
Bei anderen weiss ich nicht,
ob es möglich sein wird.
Zweiklassenmedizin.
- Ja.
Hallihallo.
- Hoi.
Die Verwandtschaft will
die Therapie selbst finanzieren.
Das Spital verlangt als Sicherheit
eine halbe Million.
Kymriah
ist eine gefährliche Therapie:
Nach der Infusion kommen einige
Patienten auf die Intensivstation.
Die liebe Gabi ...
Sie ist bereit, mir mal
50'000 als Erbvorbezug zu gewähren.
So lieb.
Bei mir ist es auch der Erbvorbezug.
Als meine Brüder ...
... das Haus kauften,
haben sie auch schon
einen Betrag so bezogen.
Ich brauchte ihn bisher nicht
und möchte das gern jetzt so tun.
(Mann) Und den kriegst du auch?
- Das sind 50'000.
Es hat mich sehr berührt,
wer im Umfeld fand:
Ich weiss, es ist so nicht viel,
aber wenn dir 10'000 Fr.
noch was bringen,
schaue ich,
dass ich die beisteuern kann.
Davon gibt es wirklich viele.
Das hat mich sehr berührt.
Denn es ist allen klar,
dass das Geld im schlimmsten Fall
einfach weg ist.
Und im allerschlimmsten Fall
hat es nichts genützt und ist weg.
Eineinhalb Jahre nach der Behandlung
bleibt der Krebs bei 40 % der
Patienten wie Michael Monstein weg,
sagt Novartis.
(Frau) Immerhin.
Aber es könnte natürlich mehr sein.
Natürlich - aber im Vergleich
zum Medikament bisher:
Da hatte ich eine
Erfolgswahrscheinlichkeit von 20 %.
Es gab Tage, an denen ich dachte:
"Das war's, es funktioniert nicht."
Da hoffte ich nur noch, dass es
am Schluss möglichst schnell geht,
damit die Familie
nicht ewig zuschauen muss,
ich nicht ewig Schmerzen habe
und nur noch als drogenzugedröhntes
Stück Gemüse rumliege.
Wegen des Preisstreits
können rund ein Dutzend Krebs-
patienten nicht behandelt werden.
Die Kritiker könnten sagen,
dass die Krankenkassen verantworten,
dass todkranke Patienten
wegen des Verhandlungspokers sterben.
Ihnen läuft die Zeit davon.
Das ist natürlich nicht so.
Wenn, ist es die Verantwortung ...
... von uns allen, dass wir
noch keine Lösung gefunden haben.
Diese Situation
ist für niemanden toll.
Michael Monsteins Familie hat
die halbe Million zusammengebracht.
Er ist der erste Schweizer
Lymphkrebspatient für Kymriah.
Unterdessen
wurden ihm Immunzellen entnommen.
Guten Morgen.
Heute werden sie versandt.
Sie gehen per Flugzeug in die USA.
Dort sollen sie zu Krebskillerzellen
gewandelt werden.
Sog. CAR-T-Zellen.
Ob das wohl gelingt?
Michael Monsteins Krebs wächst.
Für ihn zählt jeder Tag.
Die Zellen brauchen eine gewisse
Zeit, bis sie produziert werden.
Im optimalsten Fall
sind es vier Wochen.
Es kann aber auch länger dauern,
weil so viele Zellprodukte
reinkommen.
Bezüglich ... Geld.
Da hätten wir die Zuger Kantonalbank
für eine Bankgarantie. - Ja.
Es wäre ein Sperrkonto, worauf wir
alles einzahlen für den Zweck.
Wir stellen sicher, dass das
im Augenblick nicht angerührt wird.
Dann kann man weiterfahren.
Dürfte ich den Lymphknoten tasten?
- Auf jeden Fall.
Kymriah wurde aufgrund
von Patientenstudien zugelassen.
Finanziert von Novartis.
Hier spürt man:
Das sind ... mind. zwei,
aber wohl ... ja.
Experten kritisieren:
Die Wirkung von Kymriah
wurde an weniger als 100 Patienten
weltweit getestet.
Die Nachbeobachtungszeit
war kürzer als zwei Jahre.
Und Kymriah wurde nicht mit einer
bestehenden Therapie verglichen.
Darum kenne man
die langfristige Wirkung nicht.
Diese Kritik gilt generell
für Studien zu seltenen Krankheiten.
Es eilt für alle diese Patienten.
Man braucht schnellere Zulassungen.
Als Firma ist man interessiert, das
so positiv wie möglich darzustellen.
Das ist ja überall so
und intuitiv so.
Wobei: Es gab auch Studien
mit CAR-T-Zellen,
die gestoppt werden mussten,
weil es Todesfälle gab,
zu viele Nebenwirkungen.
Wie gesagt ...
- Das ist schon verrückt?
Ja, wobei man sagen muss:
Wir reden hier von Patienten,
die sonst an der Krankheit
sterben werden.
Nicht Herr Monstein, aber sie
haben oft viele Begleiterkrankungen.
Die Welt ist ungeduldig geworden,
unsere Patienten auch.
Da wartet man nicht fünf Jahre.
Das ist das Problem.
Die Studie mit den Todesfällen
betraf nicht Novartis.
Novartis macht Folgestudien
zu Sicherheit und Wirkung.
Was sagen Sie zum Preis
von 370'000 Fr. von Novartis?
Ich muss sagen:
Zu den Preisen allgemein,
also nicht auf Novartis bezogen,
sondern auf die Pharmaindustrie:
Ich finde die Preise
in vielen Bereichen horrend.
Ich finde aber,
dass das wohl Dinge sind,
die für uns, Patienten wie Ärzte,
nicht durchschaubar sind.
Aber offenbar erlaubt es denen
jemand, so hohe Preise zu verlangen.
Da stecken bestimmte Interessen
dahinter,
warum man sich
mit den Firmen gutstellen möchte.
Was glauben Sie?
- Standorte.
Weil die natürlich alle in Indien
oder China produzieren könnten.
Die Arbeitsplätze in Basel also?
Arbeitsplätze, na ja ...
Und natürlich, Beispiel Schweiz:
So viel Industrie usw.
hat die Schweiz nicht.
Aber sie haben einige weltweit
wirklich wichtige Pharmakonzerne.
Im Novartis-Werk in Stein/AG
treffen wir den Europa-
verantwortlichen für Gentherapien:
Emanuele Ostuni.
Er will uns zeigen,
dass Kymriah ab nächstem Jahr
auch in der Schweiz produziert wird.
In dieser Halle.
Wie viele Kymriah-Infusionen
können Sie hier herstellen?
Im Moment planen wir ... Nein?
Ich bin mir nicht sicher,
ob wir die genaue Zahl nennen.
Dies wird ein ...
wichtiger Standort.
This will be a key site for us.
Über Zahlen
spricht man hier nicht gern.
Lieber werden die hohen
Sicherheitsbestimmungen demonstriert.
Absitzen, reingreifen ...
Jetzt kann man arbeiten.
Arme nie kreuzen.
Können Schweizer Patienten
einen Preisabschlag erwarten,
wenn die Transportkosten in die USA
wegfallen?
"Nein", sagt Ostuni.
Der Produktionsort
spiele keine Rolle für den Preis.
Relevant
sei der Wert einer Gentherapie,
der Wert von gewonnener Lebenszeit.
Ein Paradigmenwechsel.
Früher rechtfertigte
die Pharmaindustrie ihre Preise
mit hohen Forschungskosten.
Die Prämienzahler wissen nicht,
ob 370'000 Fr. gerechtfertigt sind,
wenn sie die Herstellungs-
und Forschungskosten nicht kennen.
Diese Zahlen
veröffentlichen wir nicht.
Warum? Sind sie geheim?
- Sie sind geheim.
Wir fokussieren darauf,
was Kymriah den Patienten, dem
System und der Gesellschaft bringt.
Wenn Sie mit dem Wert argumentieren,
können wir
mit Antibiotika vergleichen:
Sie retten das Leben eines Kindes
mit Lungenentzündung.
Warum aber kosten die nur
einige 100 Fr. und nicht 1/2 Mio.?
Ich bin nicht in der Lage, die Frage
für diese Therapie zu beantworten.
Was ich erklären kann:
Wo sehen wir den Wert von Kymriah?
Das Prinzip von wertbasierten Preisen
sei falsch, sagen Krankenkassen,
weil ein Menschenleben
unbezahlbar sei.
Die Kassen schätzen, dass sich die
Prämien wegen der Medikamentenkosten
innert zehn Jahren
um über 10 % verteuern.
Befürchten Sie nicht, dass das
Gesundheitssystem zusammenbricht,
wenn Sie so weitermachen?
Nein, ich habe keine Angst.
Ich denke, wir finden Lösungen.
Wir sind offen für ...
- ... Rabatte?
Wir sind bereit, mit den Kassen
und Kantonen Risiken einzugehen,
um die Therapien
zugänglich zu machen.
"Risk sharing",
sagt die Pharmabranche.
Die Prämienzahler
tragen das Risiko mit.
Das Risiko für Kymriah,
das im Übrigen gar nicht
bei Novartis erfunden wurde.
Die Spur der Krebskillerzellen führt
an die Pennsylvania-Universität.
Kein Einzelfall.
Über 60 % der neu zugelassenen
Medikamente in den USA
stammen nicht aus Pharmalabors.
Ich heisse Carl June
und bin Immunologe.
Mein Team hat Kymriah 2004 erfunden.
Heute bin ich 65, aber ich arbeite
seit 1992 an diesem Projekt.
Carl June:
Letztes Jahr vom "Time Magazine"
zu einer der weltweit 100
einflussreichsten Personen gekürt.
Zuerst testeten wir
die Zelltherapie bei HIV-Patienten,
weil sie viel Immunzellen
verloren haben.
Zwei Jahre später
starb meine Frau an Eierstockkrebs.
Dann habe ich meine Forschung
auf Krebs verlagert.
Damals aber habe er keinen Dollar
von der Pharma erhalten.
Hi.
Dies, weil die Forschung zuerst nur
bei Mäusen, nicht Menschen wirkte.
Ohne Spendengelder hätten wir diese
Therapie nie entwickeln können.
Philanthropen und die Regierung
haben uns unterstützt.
Waren es Millionen?
Ja, es waren sicher 20 Mio., die ich
zwischen 1999 und 2012 bekam.
2012 begann die Zusammenarbeit
mit Novartis.
Die riskanteste Phase
wurde also mit Steuergeld bezahlt?
Ja, die ganze Grundlagenforschung,
die zeigte, dass das Konzept
der Krebskillerzellen funktioniert,
wurde an Universitäten gemacht.
2010 der Durchbruch
bei Krebspatient Douglas Olson.
Um die Welt aber ging die Geschichte
der siebenjährigen Emily Whitehead.
Das Leukämie-kranke Mädchen
konnte dank Kymriah gerettet werden.
Auch sieben Jahre nach der Infusion
ist Emily noch krebsfrei.
Bei Kindern wirkt Kymriah besser
als bei Erwachsenen.
Damals riefen uns
Hunderte Investoren an -
glücklicherweise auch Novartis - die
die Forschung vermarkten wollten.
Die Erfindung sei das Eine,
sagt Novartis,
die Forschung aber auf den Markt
zu bringen, sei aufwendig und teuer.
Insider sagen, Novartis habe der Uni
für das exklusive Verkaufsrecht
von Kymriah rund 225 Mio. bezahlt.
Und für jede Infusion
bezahle Novartis der Uni
rund 5 % des Verkaufspreises.
Der Konzern kommentiert das nicht.
Die Gesundheitsindustrie
ist nicht transparent.
Sie wurde nicht
zum Nutzen des Patienten geschaffen.
Bei uns an der Uni
kosten die Krebskillerzellen
rund 55'000 $ pro Patient -
ohne Gewinn.
Fast siebenmal günstiger, also.
Die Uni macht aber
nur kleine Studien mit Kymriah.
Für die Marktzulassung
musste Novartis
weltweite Studien finanzieren
und hat Zentren für die Herstellung
der Therapie gebaut.
Michael Monstein wartet immer noch
auf seine Krebskillerzellen
aus den USA.
Plötzlich
eine Nachricht von Novartis:
Der Konzern schenkt ihm Kymriah.
Ich weiss nur noch,
dass wir uns wahnsinnig freuten.
Eine riesige Erleichterung.
Denn es geht
um einen wahnsinnig hohen Betrag.
Wie ist es für den nächsten Patienten
von Kymriah?
Das weiss ich nicht.
Ich kenne die Pläne nicht.
Ich meine: Ethisch ist es eine heikle
Frage, wem Novartis das schenkt.
Ja, natürlich.
Man habe den ersten beiden Schweizer
Patienten Kymriah geschenkt,
weil sich die Verhandlungen mit den
Krankenkassen in die Länge ziehen,
heisst es bei Novartis.
Michael Monstein, Familienvater.
Er wird
den Lauf gegen die Zeit verlieren.
Novartis USA teilt mit,
man habe seine Krebskillerzellen
zu wenig gut vermehren können,
um Kymriah herzustellen.
19 Tage später stirbt er.
Ich heisse Paul Kleutghen.
Ich habe 30 Jahre lang
in der Pharmaindustrie gearbeitet.
Zuletzt als CEO.
Jetzt bin ich pensioniert, und seit
fünf Jahren leide ich an Krebs.
Dies sind die Medikamente,
die ich täglich nehmen muss.
Diese Pillen sind die wichtigsten,
sie sind gegen Krebs.
Pro Tag muss ich eine Kapsel nehmen.
Ein Stück kostet 750 $.
Interessanterweise
werden sie für 1 $ hergestellt.
Was halten Sie vom Preis
von 370'000 Fr. für Kymriah?
Es ist verrückt.
Dieses Produkt wurde auf Kosten
der US-Steuerzahler hergestellt.
Sahen Sie die Pharmaindustrie
früher mit anderen Augen?
Die Antwort ist ja.
Und zwar aus zwei Gründen.
Erstens war ich nicht Patient.
Und zweitens
war ich Teil des Systems.
Meine Familie hat davon profitiert.
Ich wusste es damals nicht besser.
Ich hatte
die Firmensicht verinnerlicht.
Wenn du älter wirst,
weitet sich deine Perspektive.
Paul Kleutghen war CEO einer Firma,
die 2002
von Novartis übernommen wurde.
Er sagt, bei Kymriah habe Novartis
auch von einem 50%igen Steuerrabatt
für die Kosten
ihrer Studien profitiert.
Die USA belohnen damit
Forschung zu seltenen Krankheiten.
Wir Steuerzahler haben einen Teil
der Entwicklung von Kymriah bezahlt.
Als Gegenleistung kriegen wir von
Novartis einen Schlag ins Gesicht.
Er hat ein Preismodell
für Kymriah erstellt.
Es basiert
auf den Angaben von Novartis,
man habe über 1 Mrd. $ investiert
bis zur Zulassung auf dem Markt.
Ich habe einen fairen Preis
für Kymriah errechnet.
In diesem Jahr
liegt er bei 200'000 $.
Dies unter der Bedingung,
dass 1'700 Patienten in den USA
und in Europa behandelt werden.
1'700 von
potenziell rund 14'000 Patienten.
Out of 14'000 potential ...
- Out of 14'000 potential patients.
Wenn mehr Patienten
behandelt werden,
kann der Preis gesenkt werden.
Und zwar auf rund die Hälfte
von 370'000 Fr.
Der faire Preis ist so berechnet,
dass Novartis
den durchschnittlichen Betriebsgewinn
von 20,7 % erreicht.
Einberechnet
sind auch die Forschungskosten
von durchschnittlich 17,3 %.
Auch der Krankenkassenverband
santesuisse
fordert 200'000 Fr. für Kymriah.
Ich habe das Modell angeschaut.
Es ist voller
inkorrekter Informationen.
Dann geben Sie mir
die richtigen Zahlen!
Das kann ich nicht -
das sind nicht unsere Daten.
Die Kritik an der Intransparenz
der Pharma wächst weltweit.
Bei der Weltgesundheitsorganisation,
den Krankenkassen
und in der Bevölkerung,
die die Prämien bezahlt.
Befürchten Sie nicht
einen Image-Schaden für Novartis?
Nein, ich sehe keinen Imageschaden
für uns.
Das ganze System
muss transparent sein,
nicht nur eine Partei.
Unsere Regierung
verlangt Transparenz,
veröffentlicht Medikamentenpreise -
es ist genau umgekehrt.
Das könnte man breiter diskutieren,
das ist etwas anderes.
* Feine, zögerliche Klänge *
Wenn er genug Kraft habe,
trainiere er mit seinen Hunden,
sagt Kurt Benninger aus Bern.
Auch der 71-Jährige
hat Lymphdrüsenkrebs.
Wegen des Preisstreits
musste er drei Monate
auf den Entscheid seiner Krankenkasse
warten, für Kymriah aufzukommen.
Könnten Sie sich das leisten,
wenn die Kasse nicht zahlen würde?
Wenn ich zu 100 % sicher wäre,
dass es gut kommt,
würde ich das Haus verkaufen.
Aber das kann ich nicht,
falls es nicht gut kommt -
dann hat die Frau auch nichts mehr.
Das würde ich nicht machen.
Also: Zahlt die Gesellschaft nicht,
würden Sie es nicht machen?
Nein, es ist mir zu riskant.
Weil die Heilungschancen nicht so ...
- Ja.
Rund 110 Kymriah-Patienten
gibt es in der Schweiz pro Jahr.
Krebskranke, bei denen
alle Therapien versagt haben.
Dazu gehört auch Anton Schlösser,
64, Lehrer im Bündnerland.
Es wird wieder heissen:
Was ist ein Menschenleben wert?
Das ist sehr hart gesagt, aber wenn
ein junger Mensch nun sagen würde:
"Sie sind schon über 60, wie viel
Lebensspanne haben Sie noch?"
"Selbst wenn es im besten Fall
eine Heilung gibt: Ist es das wert?"
Schmerzt es Sie, so etwas zu hören?
Nein. Ich habe im Spital
auch Junge kennengelernt.
Ich habe auch das Gefühl, dass sie
es nötiger hätten, böse gesagt.
Ich hatte mein Leben
ja einigermassen.
Ich kann sagen, es war soweit schön.
Ich schäme mich fast.
Obwohl ich den Preis
ja nicht festgesetzt habe.
Aber es ist sehr unangenehm.
Man fühlt sich fast schuldig.
Aber es ist das Einzige,
was es für ihn noch gibt,
da sagt man sicher nicht Nein.
Fühlen Sie sich denn
etwas schuldig?
Eigentlich nicht,
weil ich sehr lange gesund war.
Ich habe Jahrzehnte lang einbezahlt
und nie etwas gebraucht.
Ich war nie beim Arzt.
Daher kam es schon überraschend.
Auch seine Krankenkasse
bezahlt für Kymriah.
Die Preisverhandlungen der Kassen
mit Novartis dauerten vier Monate.
Wie auf einem Basar
sei es zu und her gegangen.
Einige Kassen verliessen den Tisch,
andere einigten sich mit Novartis.
Insider sagen, die Kassen
wollten 45 % Rabatt
für Kymriah gegen Lymphkrebs.
Zu viel für Novartis.
Die Vertragspartner hätten sich
auf rund 20-30 % Rabatt geeinigt,
je nach Erfolg von Kymriah.
Also etwa 250'000-300'000 Fr.
Darüber sprechen aber will niemand.
Denn die Vereinbarung
ist vertraulich.
Sie ist sogar so geheim,
dass Krankenkassen wie die Concordia,
die nicht Teil des Deals sind,
den Rabatt erst erfahren,
wenn sie den Vertrag
unterschrieben haben.
Das finde ich skandalös.
Es ist das erste Mal,
soweit ich mich erinnern kann,
dass wir einen Vertrag abschliessen
sollen, ohne den Preis zu kennen.
Das ist absolut neu
im Schweizer Gesundheitswesen.
Preise und Vertragsinhalte
sind sonst transparent vorhanden.
Sie können nachschauen, was Sie für
eine Spitalbehandlung zahlen müssen.
Kostentransparenz ist
sehr wichtig im Gesundheitswesen,
Sonst liefern wir uns
den Grossunternehmen völlig aus.
"Vogel friss oder stirb", sagt er.
Geheimrabatt
oder den vollen Preis von 370'000.
Ich denke nicht, dass das zutrifft.
So gehen wir nicht
mit unseren Partnern um.
Wir finden Lösungen.
Heisst das, Sie wären einverstanden
damit, den Rabatt zu veröffentlichen?
Wir finden Lösungen mit unseren
Partnern und stellen sicher,
dass sie nachhaltig sind.
Sie beantworten meine Frage nicht.
Ich erkläre Ihnen, was wir glauben.
Tatsache ist, dass die Pharma ihre
Rabatte noch nie veröffentlicht hat.
Okay. Wechseln wir das Thema!
Kurt Benninger
muss nochmals zur Zellentnahme.
In den USA
ist es Novartis nicht gelungen,
die Killerzellen herzustellen.
Gleich wie bei Michael Monstein.
Es ist kein gutes Gefühl,
das ist klar.
Am Anfang hat es gut ausgesehen,
aber zuletzt hatte es zu wenige.
Es braucht vermutlich schon etwas
Vertrauen in die Pharmaindustrie,
in Novartis,
wenn Sie denen Ihre Zellen übergeben?
Ja. Die wollen natürlich auch das
Beste tun. Sie wollen gut dastehen.
In der Kymriah-Zulassungsstudie
konnte 1/3 der Patienten
gar nicht behandelt werden.
Entweder liessen sich
die Killerzellen nicht herstellen,
oder die Patienten wurden während der
Wartezeit zu krank oder verstarben,
wie Michael Monstein.
Good news derweil aus den USA
für Anton Schlösser.
Bei ihm hat's geklappt.
Die Krebskillerzellen
sind auf dem Weg in die Schweiz.
Dann bekommen Sie diese Immunzellen
zurück, diese CAR-T-Zellen.
Die sind deutlich stärker als
normalerweise Immunzellen sind.
Und was passiert,
wenn Immunzellen in Aktion sind?
Es gibt Nebenwirkungen:
Es kann Fieber
oder Kreislaufprobleme geben.
Die andere Sache,
über die wir sprechen müssen,
sind neurologische Nebenwirkungen.
Die sind ebenfalls sehr häufig.
In Studien erleiden sie
zwischen 10-40 % der Patienten.
Die können ganz unspezifisch sein,
Dinge wie Sprechstörungen,
Konzentrationsstörungen.
Es kann ebenso sein,
dass Organe in der Zeit
vorübergehend etwas ausfallen,
wie z.B. die Niere. Das wurde bei
rund 20 % der Patienten beobachtet.
Diese Patienten
mussten tatsächlich zur Dialyse,
also zur Blutwäsche.
Krebskillerzellen können heilen -
und töten.
Sie sind die Therapie
der letzten Hoffnung für Patienten,
die sonst sterben.
* Drängende Klänge *
Mein Name ist Alfred Scheidegger.
Ich bin Risikokapitalinvestor.
Ich bin hier in San Francisco an
der grössten Health-Care-Konferenz.
Alfred Scheidegger investiert
in kleine Biotech-Firmen,
die neue Krebsmedikamente entwickeln.
Have a good day!
Sein Ziel: die kleinen Firmen mit
Gewinn an Pharmakonzerne verkaufen.
Ja, das wünsche ich dir auch.
Wie läuft's? - Super!
How are you doing?
- We're actually doing okay.
I know it's painful
to see the start.
Alles Gute. Tschüss!
Herr Scheidegger, was geht hier ab?
Ja, das ist wie ein Hochzeitsmarkt.
Es ist unglaublich.
Man trifft hier alle Biotech-Firmen,
v.a. auch mit Onkologiefokus.
Pharmafirmen,
die wir dann übernehmen,
zu einem späteren Zeitpunkt,
wenn sie ihren Beweis am Menschen
erbracht haben,
dass sie Krebsmedikamente haben.
In unserem Fall.
Beweis am Menschen?
Wie bitte?
- Beweis am Menschen?
Beweis am Menschen.
Man muss ein neues Medikament
ja am Menschen testen.
60 % der neuen Medikamente werden
nicht von der Pharma entwickelt,
sondern von kleinen Biotech-Firmen.
Für die Studien mit Patienten
brauchen sie viel Geld.
Und dieses kommt von Investoren wie
Alfred Scheidegger und Markus Hosang.
Haben Sie ein Stück weit
die Rolle der Pharma übernommen?
Ja, das kann man sagen.
Das begann sich
schon vor 20 Jahren abzuzeichnen.
Die Wissenschaft ist zu breit,
es ist zu viel da.
Die Pharmaindustrie kann,
will und mag nicht alles machen.
Neue Durchbrüche kommen meist
von aussen, von Universitäten her.
Diese müssen aber
raufgebracht werden.
Wir Venture-Leute sind da
eine Art Bindeglied dazwischen.
Da helfen wir, Risiko rauszunehmen,
aber dafür müssen wir
mit einer Prämie belohnt werden.
Wenn wir einen grossen Erfolg haben
und eine Firma verkaufen können,
oder unsere Aktien
an der Börse verkaufen können,
wenn das gut gelaufen ist, kann
ein Fünffaches davon herausschauen,
was wir investiert haben,
vielleicht sogar ein Siebenfaches.
Dafür haben wir aber auch
ein sehr hohes Ausfallrisiko.
Nicht jedes Krebsmedikament
funktioniert am Ende.
Aber die Pharma,
wenn Sie so viel Geld ...
Für die Pharmapreise
ist das fast irrelevant.
Sind Sie sicher?
Nicht irrelevant, aber es ist
sicher nicht der grösste Betrag.
Seine Firma investiere oft
in der frühen Phase der Forschung.
Die Pharma aber
zahle dann am meisten,
wenn eine Biotech-Firma davorstehe,
ein neues Medikament
auf den Markt zu bringen.
Novartis kauft die US-Firma AveXis
für fast 9 Mrd. $.
Gilead kauft die Biotechfirma Kite
für fast 12 Mrd.
Für die AveXis-Therapie
verlangt Novartis nun den Rekordpreis
von 2,1 Mio. $.
Das hat einen gewissen Einfluss
auf den Preis,
denn das sind ja
zusammenhängende Berechnungen.
Man muss die Investition
wieder rausholen,
das ist selbstverständlich am Ende
ein Bestandteil des Marktpreises.
Bei Kymriah konnte Novartis
durch den Vertrag mit der Universität
Biotechfirmen und Investoren
auslassen und so Milliarden sparen.
Beim Inselspitalpatienten
Kurt Benninger
hat die Herstellung von Kymriah
im zweiten Anlauf geklappt.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
43 ml für 370'000 Fr.
Auf diese Diskussion
möchte ich mich hier am Krankenbett
ehrlich gesagt nicht einlassen.
Ich hänge einfach
noch zu sehr am Leben.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
das kann's noch nicht gewesen sein.
Die Hoffnung ist jetzt sehr gross?
- Ja.
Anton Schlösser hat seine Infusion
vor zwei Tagen bekommen.
Jetzt sind wir wieder da.
Wie ist es, wie geht's?
Gut. Ausser ...
- Müde. Ja.
Ich schlafe sowieso ein,
wenn ich etwas schauen will.
Merkt man schon,
ob Kymriah wirkt oder nicht?
Nein, es ist etwas zu früh.
Wir hoffen natürlich, und wir ...
Aber es ist zu früh.
Wir haben natürlich hohe
Erwartungen, aber das wäre ...
Ich muss kurz rangehen.
Müller.
Am Apparat: eine Kantonsvertreterin.
Neue Probleme mit Kymriah.
Weil die Therapie
als Spitalbehandlung gilt,
müssen die Kantone
55 % der Kosten übernehmen.
Nein, wir starten das ja parallel,
denn das beisst sich in den Schwanz:
Die Krankenkasse gibt die Kostengut-
sprache nur unter Vorbehalt dessen,
dass der Kanton seinen Teil trägt,
und Sie sagen das Umgekehrte.
Darum lasse ich das parallel laufen.
Jeder von Ihnen beiden sagt,
dass er es nur macht,
wenn der andere zugestimmt hat.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Wir gehen nun zu Jenny Lee.
Sie ist Investmentbankerin
aus Hongkong und deckt China ab.
China macht die meisten Studien
zu Krebskillerzellen weltweit.
Marktbeobachter sagen:
Wenn die Therapie
dort zugelassen ist,
werde sie rund 70'000 $ kosten.
Hi, Jenny.
Freddy. Nice to meet you again.
We met last time in Hongkong.
It was great. - Yeah, yeah.
Jenny Lee sagt,
die chinesische Regierung
setze die Pharmakonzerne unter Druck.
Sie mussten
ihre Medikamente verbilligen,
um zugelassen werden.
Und die Pharma spielte mit.
Als Gegenleistung können die Firmen
viel grössere Mengen verkaufen.
Yeah. It's the volume.
Wenn die Pharma
die Preise hoch hält,
sind sie zu teuer für
den chinesischen Gesundheitsmarkt.
Dann verlieren wir alle.
Die Frage ist: Soll der Markt
so extrem spielen in einem Bereich,
den die Gesellschaft bezahlen muss?
Dann müssten Sie
die Pharmafirmen verstaatlichen.
Nicht unbedingt.
20-25 % Gewinnmarge hat sonst
niemand, nicht mal eine Bank.
Aber das Wachstum der
Pharmaindustrie ist nicht so hoch.
Aber man könnte die Rendite auf ein
vernünftiges Mass runterschrauben,
dann macht man immer noch Geld
und könnte sich als gesellschaftlich
bewusst und verantwortlich feiern.
Wie gesagt, ich glaube,
die Pharmafirmen
tragen eine hohe Verantwortung,
indem sie sehr viel Kapital in hoch
riskante Innovation investieren.
Insofern tragen sie eine grosse
Verantwortung für die Gesellschaft.
Ob am Ende 25 % Gewinn
erzielt werden oder 10 % ...
Geht es um Profit oder Leben?
Pharmaf...
Also.
Die existenzielle Berechtigung
einer privatwirtschaftlichen Firma
ist, dass sie Profit erwirtschaftet.
Vor Leben?
So können Sie
die Frage nicht stellen.
Jetzt gehen wir ins Hilton
zum Speeddating mit kleinen Firmen,
die während einer halben Stunde
mit uns reden können
und uns ihre Geschichte
verkaufen können, ihren Pitch.
Dann schauen wir,
ob wir investieren wollen.
Big business von den Finanzen her,
aber auch für die Medizin,
die Patienten, die Gesundheit.
It's a zoo, aber I like it.
Und das seit vielen Jahren.
Matchmaking im 30-Min.-Takt.
In diesen Kabinen
treffen sich Investoren und Forscher.
Hi, Paul.
- Hi, Markus.
Good seeing you! Finally.
- How's the conference?
Sollen
für überlebenswichtige Therapien
die gleichen Preisregeln gelten
wie für Luxusgüter?
Bei einem Porsche
haben Sie ja keine Ahnung,
wie viel der Motor, die Entwicklung,
der Showroom gekostet haben.
Wie viel der Händler,
der Zwischenhändler machen.
Den Porsche bezahlt
auch nicht die Öffentlichkeit.
Trotzdem.
Sie verlangen eine Transp...
Am Ende sind es auch Kassen.
Die Öffentlichkeit hat kein Recht,
in jedem Fall immer alles zu wissen.
Ich glaube,
die Öffentlichkeit muss sagen:
"Hier habe ich ein Angebot -
wie viel ist es mir wert?"
Anton Schlössers Frau dokumentiert
seine Therapie mit dem Handy.
Sind Sie traurig?
- Nein.
Depressiv?
- Auch nicht.
Nervös?
- Nein.
In den ersten Tagen:
Fieber und Schüttelfrost.
Nur leichte Nebenwirkungen
der Killerzellen.
Jetzt gibt es den Idiotentest.
Wo sind wir genau?
- Universitätsspital Zürich.
Dann dürfen Sie zwei Finger zeigen.
Sich ans Ohr fassen.
Und die Augen schliessen.
Dasselbe Bild am Inselspital.
Auch Kurt Benninger bekommt Fieber,
aber sonst geht es ihm gut.
Haben Sie subjektiv das Gefühl,
es nützt etwas?
Das kann ich nicht sagen.
Das weiss man noch nicht.
Hi, I'm Markus.
- Shawn Carbonell, nice to meet you.
Diese Biotechfirma
forscht in einem Bereich, der boomt:
Medikamente für seltene Krankheiten,
sog. Orphan Drugs.
Auch Kymriah ist ein Orphan Drug.
Wir fokussieren
auf seltene Krankheiten.
Das Gesetz bietet Anreize dafür.
Wir kennen eine Firma,
die nur acht Patienten testete,
und nur zwei davon sprachen teil-
weise auf das neue Medikament an.
Dennoch wurde es
im Schnellverfahren zugelassen.
Kleinere Patientengruppen,
kürzere Studiendauer, Steuerrabatte.
Für Orphan Drugs gebe es
noch einen weiteren grossen Vorteil,
sagt Investor Scheidegger.
Let's go!
In den USA und der EU
erhalten Orphan Drugs
ein exklusives Vermarktungsrecht.
Bis zu zehn Jahre lang
werden ähnliche Produkte
von Konkurrenten nicht zugelassen.
Das Gesetz ist so gemacht,
dass es sich eben lohnt,
wenn man die Marktzulassung bekommt,
dass man über mehrere Jahre hinweg
eine gewisse Exklusivität hat.
D.h. ein Konkurrent kann
nicht einfach auf den Markt kommen.
Sondern man bekommt
eine gewisse Exklusivität.
Wenn es nichts anderes gibt,
hat man wahrscheinlich freiere
Spielräume für die Preisgestaltung.
Das bedeutet,
dass das wohl mit ein Grund ist,
warum die Krebsmedikamente
so teuer wurden.
Ich sage mal, das ist ein Grund,
aber längst nicht der einzige.
In den USA wurde
das Gesetz für seltene Krankheiten
vor über 30 Jahren geschaffen.
Heute kritisiert der Politiker,
der es initiiert hatte,
einige Pharmafirmen
würden das Monopol ausnützen
um ihre Gewinne zu steigern.
Orphan Drugs und Marktexklusivität:
Das Thema erreichte
vor einigen Jahren auch die Schweiz.
Geschätzte Kolleginnen und Kollegen,
gemäss Ratsreglement
lege ich zu Beginn der Debatte
zu diesem Geschäft
meine Interessenbindung offen:
Ich bin Präsident von Intergenerika,
dem Schweizerischen Verband
der Generika-
und Biosimilar-Hersteller.
Um die Entwicklung von Arzneimitteln
für seltene Krankheiten zu fördern,
sollen die Pharmaunternehmen
für sog. Orphan Drugs
während zehn Jahren
die Marktexklusivität erhalten.
Während dieser Frist dürfte für die
gleiche therapeutische Indikation
kein anderes Arzneimittel
zugelassen werden,
es sei denn, es werde
nachweislich sicherer und wirksamer.
Der Punkt ist: Pharmafirmen
sind keine sozialen Einrichtungen.
Sie forschen nur,
wenn sie Gewinn erwarten.
Damit es überhaupt
zu neuen Medikamenten
für seltene Krankheiten kommt,
braucht es ein Monopol.
Dieses wird durch
die Marktexklusivität geschaffen.
Als Sebastian Frehner
ins Parlament kam,
gab er einen Zugangsbadge
dem damaligen Interessensvertreter
von Novartis.
Novartis und Roche spendeten den
bürgerlichen Parteien letztes Jahr
fast 900'000 Fr.
Am Ende der Debatte
müssen wir feststellen,
dass nicht die Patientinnen
und Patienten
durch diese Revision des
Heilmittelgesetzes gewonnen haben,
sondern dass es
im Wesentlichen darum ging,
welche Taschen
noch besser gefüllt werden können.
Während der ganzen
Kommissionsberatung
und auch heute hier im Saal
hat mich das Gefühl begleitet,
dass ich und mit mir
vielleicht andere auch noch
nur einen Bruchteil dessen
durchschauen, was im Hintergrund
hier an Lobbyarbeit
und Interessensvertretung läuft.
Das hatte dann Konsequenzen.
Ich bekam eine Rüge
von Pascal Brenneisen,
der damals
bei Novartis Inlandchef war.
Schweiz-Chef, ja.
Was hat er denn gesagt?
Er schrieb uns,
Beat Jans und mir, eine Mail,
dass er uns gerne treffen wolle,
also mit uns
über unsere Haltung reden wolle.
Wir verhielten uns bei dieser
Gesetzgebung nicht pharmafreundlich.
Ich empfand das
als ungehörige Einmischung
in meine parlamentarische Arbeit.
Hat es so etwas je zuvor gegeben?
Ich habe das weder vorher
noch nachher je erlebt.
Zwei Jahre dauerte die Debatte.
Der Nationalrat stimmte zweimal
für die Marktexklusivität,
der Ständerat aber war dagegen.
Das Monopol kam nicht durch,
dafür eine abgeschwächte Massnahme,
die Orphan Drugs schützt.
Einen Monat
nach der Infusion mit Kymriah.
Anton Schlösser
wird umfassend untersucht.
Hat Kymriah funktioniert?
Ist der Krebs verschwunden?
Ich zeige Ihnen
erst noch mal in die alten Bilder.
Da war hier dieser Bollen
um den Port rum.
Und dann war die Hauptmasse
hier in der Muskelloge.
Und dann natürlich am Unterschenkel,
hier, ganz viel.
Jetzt kommt nachher ...
... wo man
nur noch flaue Aktivität hat.
Da tut sich schon noch was,
hier in der Muskelloge,
aber es ist doch deutlich weniger.
Für mich ist das ... Ich hätte es
mir nicht besser vorstellen können.
Bei dieser Tumormasse,
die vorher da war -
dass es ganz weg wäre
ohne Spuren der Entzündung noch ...
Kann man sagen,
dass er über dem Berg ist,
oder kann der Krebs
auch wieder zurückkommen?
Also, wir haben keine Glaskugel,
das wissen wir so natürlich nicht.
Aber es ist ein guter Start.
Eine Rückkehr
können Sie nicht ausschliessen?
Das kann man nie,
und dafür sind die Kymriah-Daten,
die Behandlungsdaten
mit CAR-T-Zellen noch zu kurz.
Unterdessen am Inselspital.
Auch Kurt Benningers Krebs
ist unmittelbar nach der Behandlung
verschwunden.
Ich bin natürlich froh,
dass ich nach Hause kann.
Und die hier
nicht mehr anziehen muss.
Weiterhin alles Gute.
Geniessen Sie den Moment!
Merci.
Ich komme am Montag ja wieder.
Sein Arzt
will noch nicht Bilanz ziehen.
Laut Novartis-Studie
zeigt sich erst nach rund einem Jahr,
bei welchen Patienten
der Lymphkrebs wegbleibt.
Über die Hälfte sterben.
Und: Wie die Krebskillerzellen sich
im Körper langfristig entwickeln,
weiss niemand.
Es klang gut, jetzt.
- Mh.
Schöne neue Medizinwelt.
Rekordteure Hoffnung aufs Überleben.
Kymriah jedenfalls
ist nur der Anfang.